buongiorno ragazzi oggi siamo in un
video molto particolare perché era da un
po che non facevo i dialetti cosa sono
gli eletti il dialetto è quella parlata
magica di ogni regione che può in italia
è così come voi siete tanti iscritti al
canale
vedremo se provenite da tutta italia ci
sono youtuber americani che fanno prova
parlava vostra lingua e parlano
brasiliano insomma tutte le lingue dei
loro follower posso solo farmaco i
dialetti ma lo facciamo perché diventa
bellissimo quando prova a tradurre le
cose che voi dite che non si capisce mai
una sega proviamoci
partiamo con il primo ragazzi da laura
che ci manda questo la frase sarebbe
chiusa e che ha caricato che significa è
non modo il subito non me lo dire subito
in un side e lane
chi è che ci ha caricato allora te non
sai l'ho capito se non sai se per nuda
scaricato uno che si chiama pierno piero
piero ha caricato piero a dirlo subito e
non sai in che situazione dice li
mortacci è sostituito e piero che
magistrato porca che non fosse stato per
piero
andiamo avanti però l'inizio normale ho
fatto schifo ma posso sempre migliorare
uno scioglilingua in siciliano questo
quadro contento dai proviamo a capo
steve spicchio pose a spicchi che schifo
emmaus di più dobbiamo dirlo devo dirlo
dai dove una cosa non fermi riprendi
dovevo dirlo però dai faceva tutto rima
tranne uno spicchio un jet da ben avanti
a roma è stato da chiara grazie chiara
non capite una sega illuminami aprire lo
sportello e prendi lo spicchio poi così
lo spicchio e di te lo sportello
io continuo a non aver capito spicchio
c'è mio padre che mi sta mandando dei
messaggi vocali
va bene probabilmente perché vuole
partecipare anche lui vediamo cosa mi ha
scritto bellissimo che mi ha scritto il
primo messaggio è completamente vuoto
non so mandare i messaggi vocali
va bene papi ci hai provato secondo
messaggio a quando il qatar è che mi ha
detto mio padre non è che sto a parlare
un al non sono estraneo però pensate ai
quarti ci capiamo in casa cosa fai qua
quand'è che ti ritiri allora il discorso
è questo mio padre pugliese di fasano
quindi parla il pugliese anche mia nonna
in quindi un po lo capisco per questo
motivo lui lo parla pia non so niente
però avendo sentito in famiglia ogni
tanto parla qualcuno così più o meno
qualcosa capisco quindi credo voglia
dire cos'è i libertini qui c'è stefano
citterio a quando i catari dei grazie va
be cosa che fai qua quando che ti ritiri
credo non è ver
era che fai lì quando torni niente papa
non ho capito la ai 24 anni da giorgia
dialetto bergamasco
partiamo a brilla business
avril avril aprile
avril lavigne o un thor o una freccia
questo capito significa aprire free
letto buongiorno calcio un giorno freddo
ma dove sta avril lavigne in tutto
questo irene narraci quando che la nest
a montecagno quelle sposate favano
ragazzi però non mi dovete mandare i
messaggi in arabo ve lo dico sempre io
non io non sto capendo niente in questo
video è completamente da sottotitolare
non so nulla sa bene come significa
della merda intesa come ambizione sale
in strando italiano che sarebbe il
cristallo se non puzzava danno ciao
ma sai che ho capito meglio quella in
dialetto che questo rebecca cd un
maschio ogni tanto potrebbe anche
esserci se volete partecipare ragazzi
comunque si può fare non sono nè la
challenge dedicata alle ragazze potete
partecipare anche voi se volete non è
che ha lasciato mancino nella pelle cosa
ha lasciato macchinona usa che ha detto
guarda che ha lasciato un macchinone in
mezzo alla strada giusto una persona la
macchina e l'ha parcheggiata lungo in
mezzo alla strada
tutto qui per cui tono umbro io non di
fasano umbro di melo subito come i
pokémon umbre on
adesso vado a cercare un maschio
forzatamente porca vacca possibile
eccolo qua allora lei sì ho trovato un
alessio buono dovresti essere maschio
questo è impossibile favi beh ma la
premessa è buona chissà di tanto che
stadi non ci sembra che sia giunta l'ora
di andare a quella era quella e ragiona
frase a penso li si fosse interrotto il
vocale episodi si fosse interrotto
questa chiesta di dan dah cosa vuol dire
cosa però mi sembrate grazie alessio
preparata una presenza maschile a questo
video andiamo avanti
laura abbiamo dialetto sardo andrea mari
è la ragazza in my club
andai per mare quindi al mare e non a
cap dai non andai a mari e non a gas
time money club
manco a ba gli abba sono un gruppo
musicale non è quello dunque andrai per
mare sicuro e non a cathay non riuscì a
recuperare neanche un o acqua o un pesce
immagino quel punto però sicuramente
giusta non ci ha mandato la traduzione
quindi è un segreto però abbiamo sally
che parla dialetto siciliano dice tutto
sa lui cosa si creda poeta
e compito ne va beh questo è facile dai
quando si apre il giornale si apre
montone andava dai questa è la parte del
portone era facile questa era facile
sally la prossima grazie che mi hai
fatto azzeccare una frase lascia il
tappo sta perché mi vuole bene comunque
molto semplice o un serenata unites
romano dai ieri dovevo uscire a
contrastare ogni cucina mamma pisciato
ieri dovevo uscire a comprare il
telefono con mia cugina ma a verde e
gambe e marco lato liquido che ci
avevano in corpo katerine madonna ma
sembra che pensava dei fan italiani io
però catherine non penso tendiamo
credere in di fiducia capisco come la
cina visto il pesto con l'arrotino
prevedendo capisco come la cina non lo
so non ho capito ma nel senso di the
beast prova sentiamo cosa voleva dirci
catherine è talmente significa di testo
come l'uva però usato come ti do molte
mazzate non ha questa era poco difficile
bravi i miei messo veramente di questa
veramente un casino la prima che non
indovino extra partecipa scherzi a parte
[Musica]
la vita vi sta prendendo il risultato
per il culo e secondo me sto
partecipando a scherzi a parte manco lo
so
comunque questa martina questa grazie
mattina non senta la traduzione sono
sicuro che giusto no comunque a parte
gli scherzi ma sapete che sta cosa qua a
me capita un sacco di volte cioè nel
senso io essendo comunque conosciuto
sarebbe possibile farmi uno scherzo tipo
scherzi a parte no quindi io tante volte
tante c'è qualche volta mi è capitato di
essere nella condizione mi sembrava di
essere in uno scherzo e tante volte ho
reagito tipo ma mi state facendo uno
scherzo
essendo proprio convinto di trovare
telecamere in giro la settima volta che
mann bocciata la patente poi ha detto
dai facciamo i seri poi non era uno
scherzo però tante volte mi è capitato
di trovi in una situazione dove sembrava
veramente cioè io potrebbe esserci
veramente uno scherzi a parte su di me e
quindi io veramente mi trovi nella
situazione ogni tanto ne va avanti
grazie martina un dialetto veronese
camilla dice tutto amica mia
[Musica]
gli uomini sono con i lupi si danno da
bere e l'uno con l'altro però non ho
capito perché si devono dare da bere i
lupi che significa avere altre le tegole
sono come lei sono come di tivoli le
regole cioè le tegole le tegole enrico
un curioso corinne siciliano ciao l'ora
la frase in siciliano e studiati
commosso studiati con un super studiati
e quindi studiati 1 posso questo quello
che ho capito rassegnati e lo possono
dove sta tradotto invece letteralmente
significa pulisciti la bocca è manca
sempre il top ovunque in tutto commesso
gorin però va bene veramente sono sono
al limite di tutto questo però un po ne
ha azzeccati pochi molto pochi però sono
contento
vi ringrazio per respirare partecipato
questo video ragazzi per essere sempre
così chiari del parlare con me io non vi
capisco ma vi voglio bene l'importante
questa cosa dei ragazzi servi dove
piaciuto lasciato un bel commento mi
piace
tenetevi al canale è piaciuta la
campanina vicino al tasto iscriviti che
almeno rimanete aggiornati sui nuovi
video che escono che se non vi arriva la
notifica e noi come sempre ci rivediamo
ad un prossimo video bella ragazzi
[Musica]